الحقيقه وجودي هنا قدامكم ده كل الناس
الحلوه دي مسؤوليه كبيره جدا بالنسبه لي
اول ما حصل هنا هاقول لكم ايه حضرتك
في المكان ده
طيب
القيمه المضافه اللي انا هاقدمها كمصمن
للمجتمع عشان نعمل كده تعال نبص على الصور
دي
الصورتين دول قدامنا
بمخيلاتكم مين فيهم اكثر رفاهيه واكثر
فخامه وفي ترف كبير جدا
كل واحد فينا عنده منظور للترف
او للرفاهيه
برده نبص على الصور دي
مين فيهم باين عليه اكثر الرفاهيه او
الغنى
يعني مفهوم مختلف من بني ادم لبني ادم
والموضوع نسبي جدا طب عشان نشوف ايه معنى
كلمه
ايه اللي انت بتقوله ده طيب خلونا نشوف مع
بعض
ايه الكلام ده معناه ايه لو جينا نبص لكل
واحد فينا يفكر بالكلمه دي واحنا شوفنا
توكس تتكلم على السياحه
اماكن بعيده الرفاهيه ان احنا نكون
موجودين بحاجه ملهاش
خدمات او ممكن احنا نخلق لنفسنا عالمنا
الخاص ونحس انه اللي احنا عاملينه من ابسط
حاجه هو العالم بتاعنا هي الجمال وهي
السعاده والضحكه الحلوه دي
طيب تعالوا نشوف عشان نفهم ده نطبق الكلام
ده
في التصميم تعالوا نشوف الاول الموضوع ده
ازاي البني ادم بيستقبل المعلومات
عشان نشوف ده نشوف المخ في تجربه
ليه ازاي المخ بيستقبل المعلومات اللي
حوالينا
المربعين دول نفس اللون بالضبط شايفينهم
اكيد هم نفس اللون عشان ناكد نفس اللون
حطينا شريطين من نفس اللون برده وياكدوا
ان هم نفس اللون هنشيل بس دلوقتي الشريطين
بصوا كده هل انتم لسه شايفينهم نفس اللون
طيب يبقى نحن متاكدين انهم نفس اللون بس
ايه اللي حصل مخ هنا لما حط المربعين بنفس
اللون بمصفوفه
بوضع معين ادانا
صوره ثانيه او انعكاس ثاني للواقع لكن
بشكل مختلف جدا الكلام ده اعتقد انه مرعب
جدا لانه اكيد اكيد احنا مش مجانين احنا
شفناها بنفسنا طيب هل ده
حقيقي حقيقي
طب الالوان بس كلنا بنبص على الالوان على
الصوره دي فيها الوان كثيره قوي ناس هتقول
الخط اللي في النص اللي لونه ابيض او ده
هو اللون اللي احنا شايفينه ناس هتبص على
البنفسجي الاصفر كل واحد فينا هيبص على
لون ويقول الله الالوان دي جميله بص على
اللون الاحمر اللي فيه ورد وحب وحنان
اللون الاحمر ده اثبتت الدراسات انه نحن
لما نوريه للطلبه وهما داخلين الامتحان
بيخليهم يرتبطوا لانه بيدل على التصحيح
بتاع المدرسه
طيب تعالوا نبص على اللون الاسود اللون
الاسود اللي هو في ناس بتلبس الرجاله
بيلبس بدله الفرح لونها اسود في ناس بتروح
العزب الاسود في ناس بقوه والبطوله لابسين
اسود
موضوع غريب جدا طب هل الموضوع
اللي احنا شايفينها بس على النظر لا كمان
تعالوا نبص على
الصوت
الصوت في تجربه اتعملت على جزيئات الماء
المجمده لما نعرض الميه
ليه صوت متجانس بيطلع لنا الصوره اللي
احنا شايفينها هنا صوره
ميه متناظره لما نعرض الميه ليه ضوضاء
وضديك تتعرض بيبقى شكلها بالشكل اللي احنا
شايفينه عشوائي طب يا عم ايه القصه اللي
انت بتقولها
دي عايز اقول لكم انتم
جسمنا 70% من الميه وبالتالي لو احنا
تعرضنا لاصوات او لكلمات جيده ونحسنها
هيبقى الميه اللي جوه
العلاج بالصوت بنجيب الناس مسمعهم اصوات
تعال نشوف باقي
اللي احنا شفنا اللي فات ده تاثير المخ او
ازاي المخ بشوف الصوت وصوره باثر عليه طيب
في التصميم نفسه
يتعامل مع جسم الانسان اعرف قد ايه محيطي
حجمي
واهميته في تحسين الاداء بتاعنا واحنا
بنشتغل وده علم الاردن
واستخدموه في العربيات في عربيات
بصوا الراجل كان زمان بيقعد ازاي السواق
بصوا دلوقتي بيقعد ازاي التغيير ده حسن
جدا الاداء بتاع البني ادم طيب
في الصور اللي قدامنا بصوا على المكاتب قد
ايه جميله تحسين بيئه عمليه رائعه
والاحكام بتاعه البني ادم عملوا ترابيزات
بتطلع وتنزل عشان تفضل ظهرنا مفرود وعشان
نبقى صعيدين وعملوا فواصل ما بين الناس
عشان ياخذوا شويه تخصصيه وحاجات شكلها
جميل جدا طيب نستفيد بدا ايه هل ده
الرفاعيه
لكن زي ما احنا شوفنا قبل شويه فكره الصوت
بياثر علينا ازاي وبياثر على انتاجنا
وبالتالي جاءت شركه
المفتوح كل العناصر المستخدمه هي ممتصه
جيده للصوت وبالتالي يخلي كل الناس اللي
بيشتغلوا في المحيط ده بيشتغلوا في بيئه
الصوت فيها رائع الموضوع ده زاد انتاجيه
المكان كله
وهنا بنشوف قد ايه ده الرفاهيه في التصميم
علم ان هو ولا حاجه احنا مش شايفين انه في
انواع بس هو بالعلم
تعال
نتكلم على الضوء
احنا بطبيعتنا عايشين حياتنا مع الساعه
البيولوجيه للعالم شمس بتطلع الصبح بنبقى
كده مكسلين شويه شويه بنبقى ناشطين جدا
لحد اخر اليوم بنروح من النادي
طيب ده هل بيفرق معانا اه بيفرق معانا ده
بياثر على حياتنا كده لكن احنا مش طول
الوقت بره احنا معظم حياتنا قاعدين زي ما
احنا دلوقتي في الحيزات الداخليه
وين احنا فاهمين انه الساعه البيولوجيه
بتاعه الشمس بتاثر علينا طب كل المعلومات
دي نعمل بها ايه
في شركه عملت نظره للمدارس وقالت احنا
هنستخدم العلم بتاع البني ادم والعلم بتاع
ازاي المخ يستخدم يستقبل المعلومات
بكذا مدرسه طب بيعملوا ايه عندنا ناس
بيطلعوا المدرسه الشباب بيطلعوا الجامعه
اللي عنده عيال بيطلعوا المدرسه الصبح كله
مش قادر يروح ومش قادر يقول فيدخل الفصل
الطالب يقوم من المدرسه عالي
فا الشباب يفوق وكده ويزهقه كده ويلا
نشتغل وشويه شويه شويه بنغير درجه حراره
النور فنخلي الطلبه يبقوا متفاعلين بس مش
محتاجين نوطرهم وبعد شويه يطلعوا الفسحه
يطلعوا الفسحه بقى يكسروا ويتنطات ويعملوا
كل الحاجات هم جايين لنا ايه مشدودين اول
ما يدخل احنا مش عايزين الكهرباء دي بنقوم
مغيرين نور درجه النور
هل بس في التعليم برده في المستشفى
جربوا نفس الفكره بتاعه الحركه البيولوجيه
او الساعه البيولوجيه لينا
للمرضى مريض قاعد لا حول ولا قوه هنعمل
ايه مش عايز يتفاعل فيه كثير قوي من الاوض
ما لهاش اصلا شمس
في عمله نوع من الاضاءه بيتغير حسب وضع
المكان اللي هو فيه خارجيا وده فرق جدا
جدا جدا
بتحسين فاعليه المريض وتجاوبه
ليه العلاج طب هل بس للمريض لا والممرض
كمان او الدكاتره لانه هي فرقت معهم جدا
انها تعلي الانتاجيه بتاعتهم وما يحسوش
بالموضوع الاكتئاب اللي هما في كل مرض
وكده طب هل ده بس للبالغين لا ده هم جربوع
على الاطفال
الخدج اللي هم حديثين الولاده عملوا نوع
من الاضاءه غير مباشره بتتغير مع الساعه
البيولوجيه بتاعه المكان واكتشفه انه
العيال بتكبر احسن وزنها بيزيد اكثر
نرجع بعد كل ده ونشوفنا اللي فات ارجع لكم
بالاول خالص واسالكم نفس السؤال انتم
شايفين مين في صورتين دول الاكثر رفاهيه
او في لجدي اكثر وفخامه للبني ادم
موضوع نسبي
دلوقتي
وبطلب من كل الناس اللي بيشتغلوا في
التصميم هو في مجالنا انه لما نيجي نشتغل
ونبيع للناس اللي عملها بتوعنا موضوع
الرفاهيه
بس على ان هو خامه او شكل او منظر
للحياه فاكرين الناس اللي بيضحكوا احنا
لازم نرسم الضحكه دي على وشوشهم على وشوش
كل الناس اشكرك
[تصفيق]